what what was the thinking behind the
naming your son Boston what was that it
was that a thing you just like the name
or yeah I just love the name Boston Jay
I don't know yeah I don't know it's good
it's fair enough yeah I don't know yeah
it's English yeah you know I don't know
not Brian Brian cross my mind count
you're their uncle uncle Brian why is a
terrible name I would have fun I would
have been like change his name
immediately what Brian's a [ __ ] name
I can't stand that I I hey my dad hey
Dad number one don't name me Brian even
though your best friend's name was Brian
they'll put all the total to it back
then though yeah yeah yeah but number
two he decided to name me Brian with a
why cuz it's unique because it's unique
hey Dad no the rest of my life I gotta
go no it's Brian with it you spell it
with an i it's a why bribry [ __ ] that
dude you're 53 let's change your name
I'd love to we don't go by let me well
man dragging our ranks is my new name
now [ __ ] my name is rinks thank you
very much
rinks are manned dragon rinks or gay owl
or [ __ ] you know I got we turn a
street art art now dance I got thanks
this [ __ ] five cats
[ __ ] man ranks hey guys can't help it
today like hey rinks you sweet tart tart
NASA gay I will [ __ ] man dragon blah
blah blah thanks [ __ ] yeah alright now
I guys alright you know it's that it's
incredible it's incredible
no call just because I embody the hold
on so how is this it's about just kung
fu kung fu what you're saying
umph well that's how it's said so as I'm
from I studied in China first on